in this episode we're going to build
toast style notification messages from
scratch the messages will be saved on
the backend and firebase as well so we
can maintain a cool history of the
messages that have been sent the
messages are managed by a central
service that can be injected into any
component this makes it possible to
trigger messages from anywhere in the
app on the front-end we're using the
boma CSS framework but you could easily
swap this out for bootstrap and material
or your own custom classes let's start
by building the toast service we'll
first start by importing the angularfire
database then we'll create a custom
message class just to model our data a
message can app content is a string a
style and it can also be dismissed which
is a boolean value in the constructor we
send at the content and an optional
style argument if the style is undefined
it'll just default to PIMCO in the
service we create a function to return
the firebase list observable with the
messages in the database we want to
limit this query to the last five
messages from there we create a function
to create a new message this function
can be called anywhere from any
component and it will update the
firebase was too observable it simply
takes the content and style as arguments
and builds a new message and sends that
to the database and the last step is to
give the user the ability to dismiss
messages so we just retrieve a message
as an object and then update it if
missed attribute to true before we start
building the component I'm going to
build a custom pipe that will filter out
the dismissed messages and then send
them in reversed order so they display
one on top of the other first I import
the filter and reverse functions from
lodash and the value going into this
pipe will be an array of messages so we
can call reverse and then we can filter
out that dismiss messages and if there's
no value we just return null
now we can put the pipe to use in the
component template the messages will be
in the form of fire based lists
observable which we can unwrap with the
async pipe we can then chain our custom
reverse pipe to that to send them in
reverse order and filtered by the
dismissed attribute from there we can
use ng class to display a conditional
class based on the style of the message
we passed ng class an object where the
key is the Bulma CSS class and the value
is true or false based on how the
statement evaluates the final step is to
allow the user to dismiss the message by
clicking a button and we also display
the message content going into the type
script we first inject the toast service
into the component and then we get a
list of messages as the firebase lists
observable then we set up an event
handler to handle the click of the
button to dismiss the message in this
example I want toast messages to be
global throughout the application so I
put them in the app component outside
the scope of the router so they'll still
display even if the user navigates to
different pages now we can inject the
service and any component we want and in
this case we'll just send a few
arbitrary messages from the readme page
component if we go back to the app we
can see the database is being updated
after each button click you may or may
not want to save these messages in the
database but when you do it opens up
some possibilities to do things with
cloud functions where you could update
something in the database and then push
a message right into the user speed
[Music]
that's it for this episode if you found
the video helpful please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase comm for
just a few bucks a month you'll get
access to you exclusive content as well
as free one on one project consulting
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]